nous devons tout faire pour atteindre
nos objectifs climatiques nous devons
tout faire pour relocaliser nos
industries nous devons tout faire pour
mettre fin à nos dépendances nous devons
tout faire pour répondre aux besoins de
main d'œuvre de nos entreprises et
former nos travailleurs la réponse elle
est européenne c'est celle du net zéro
industrie Act nous posons notamment ici
les bases d'un bail européen Act cela
passera par des critères plus stricts
dans l'attribution des marchés publics
qu'ils soi sociaux ou environnementaux
pour que nos entreprises européennes ne
soient plus désavantagé cela passera par
des formations ciblées afin que les
travailleurs européens dispose des
compétences requises cela passera par un
système plus simple de permis pour les
usines de technologie propre c'est
seulement ainsi engagé en européen que
nous arriverons à garder le cap fixé
depuis le début du mandat climat
compétitivité souveraineté et tout cela
en même temps je vous remercie